un procedimiento de ligadura de trompas
es un método permanente de control de la
natalidad en el que el cirujano realiza
la sección y ligadura de las trompas de
falopio para prevenir el embarazo
el sistema reproductivo de la mujer
incluye la vagina el canal en donde se
depositan los espermas y los bebés
emergen durante el parto útero el órgano
en forma de pera donde un óvulo
fecundado se convierte en un bebé
trompas de falopio dos conductos que
transportan los óvulos desde los ovarios
hasta el útero y donde usualmente el
esperma fecunda óvulos y ovarios dos
grande las que producen y liberan óvulos
durante las relaciones sexuales el
esperma masculino es introducido en la
vagina éstos recorren un canal llamado
el cuello del útero y dentro del útero
luego el esperma se mueve hacia las
trompas de falopio en donde puede
encontrar y fecundar óvulos que han sido
liberados de los ovarios el embarazo
comienza con el óvulo fecundado si no
desea quedar embarazada puede elegir un
método de control de la natalidad de una
de las varias categorías
abstinencia
contra excepción
o esterilización para evitar
permanentemente el embarazo a través de
un procedimiento médico la ligadura de
trompas es una forma de esterilización
antes de que el procedimiento comience
se colocará una vía intravenosa y
recibirá medicamento que le ayudará a
relajarse se aplicará anestesia local
para adormecer el área de la operación y
permanecerá despierta durante ese
periodo en algunos casos se puede
utilizar anestesia general o espinal
si se está sometiendo a una ligadura de
trompas laparoscópica
el médico empezará realizando una
incisión diminuta cerca del ombligo y
otra justo sobre el hueso púbico luego
el médico inyectar a dióxido de carbono
un gas inofensivo por medio de un tubo
insertado en la incisión superior el
dióxido de carbono infla la cavidad
abdominal lo que le permite al médico
ver con claridad y trabajar alrededor de
sus órganos internos luego el médico
introducirá un instrumento con luz
llamado laparoscopia a través de una de
las incisiones en laparoscopia proyecta
imágenes de las estructuras dentro de su
abdomen en un monitor a través de la
otra incisión el médico pasará
instrumentos quirúrgicos para captar las
trompas de falopio y cerrarlas
utilizando la técnica de corte atado
bloqueo o cierre
al final del procedimiento el médico
permitirá que el dióxido de carbono se
escape y cerrará las incisiones con
puntos
si se está sometiendo a una ligadura de
trompas por mini laparotomía el médico
realizará una pequeña incisión justo
sobre su hueso púbico captará las
trompas de falopio con fórceps y la
cerrará utilizando una de varias
técnicas al final del procedimiento la
incisión será cerrada con puntos
este método es normalmente utilizado
justo después del parto si se está
sometiendo a una laparotomía
el médico realizará una incisión de 2 a
5 pulgadas en su abdomen inferior
y localizar a las trompas de falopio y
la cerrará utilizando una de varias
técnicas
al final del procedimiento la incisión
será cerrada con puntos inmediatamente
después será trasladada al área de
recuperación si tiene una ligadura de
trompas laparoscópica probablemente
regresará a casa el mismo día si tiene
una laparotomía o una mini laparotomía
luego del parto su estancia en el
hospital podría extenderse un poco